the thing I must ask you about because
when your co-stars were here yes
monuments man a Matt Damon oh my god
that joke oh there they are talking
about how mean you were to him on set
though
so you didn't torture these people not
know we know about so far okay go to
your hotel room because famous you've
this ongoing thing with Brad Pitt so
I've done some terrible things to
probably wait Brad's done some terrible
things to me good start
um I don't remember how we were doing
Ocean's eleven I think it was the first
one and I don't remember what it was I I
think initially you I get one of my
favorite things is to get those things
that go around your license plate or a
bumper sticker cuz you never go to back
of your car and look and put it on
people's cars cuz it's funny and they
can ride around you know with some
horrible you know embarrassing bumper
sticker and I put I found a bumper
sticker in the shape of a pot plan that
said [ __ ] cops
car cuz I figure that's not the way you
don't get pulled up there's no way you
got pulled over
and then he went on I think Letterman
and said you know let me ask him when he
and Angie we get married he said when
George can legally marry in the United
States and it just kept going back and
forth with that for a while and then it
was a I had stationery made up with his
name and then I would send letters to
other actors from Brad Pitt I sent Meryl
Streep a letter from Brad where I got a
big thing of CDs that had died it was a
dialect coach and he had like every
dialect you Gailen Yiddish every
dialogue you bought in this huge thing
and I send it to her with a note from
Brad that said you know I hear you're
gonna be doing the Iron Lady soon this
guy helped me with my dialect in Troy or
somebody here I thought maybe this would
help the Marilyn you know she's very
confused
I sent letter I've sent letters though
lots and lots of people from Brad any
you don't tell either
I don't tell either no I later like a
year or two years later I let him know
and then they're like are you kidding me
I'm doing one now that I can't tell you
about but in a year you're going to hear
that I've been arrested kidding cuz I
think I've crossed the line Oh
that's exciting I have a wife she's a
barrister I'll be fine
oh this thing is is it drew this
comic-con was sort of part of your
honeymoon
oh yeah that's yes man right here is
where you got to do a little tongue
thing hey this is what it gets
interesting
did you smell